bom dia a todos é queria agradecer à
equipe toda do ted x mac pelo convite
para compartilhar essa pequena
contribuição pra vocês
num é em 2007
as nações unidas estabeleceram o dia
internacional da democracia é dentro
dessa resolução em que as nações unidas
estabelece essa celebração internacional
é a palavra democracia aparece 19 vezes
dentro dessas 19 vezes nenhuma vez
aparece efetivamente uma definição do
que é a democracia a a nossa
constituição de 88 a nossa carta magna
que nos rege a a palavra democracia não
aparece nenhuma vez mas em todas esses
dois documentos
há inúmeras referências ao que seriam
valores democráticos como por exemplo a
idéia de que o poder emana do povo
ou então de que há um cidadão é aquele
que participa integralmente de todas as
atividades que o conseguem
se a gente pensar que de 88 pra cá ou
mesmo de 2007 para cá a tecnologia
evoluiu de uma forma que a gente nem
consegue acompanhar né
tenho certeza que vocês todos da hora
que acordaram até a hora que sentarão
aqui para assistir todas essas conversas
hoje já usaram o celular de vocês já
usaram tecnologia de uma forma múltipla
né eu mesma da manhã até aqui já usei
tecnologia para treinar minha própria
fala aqui no ted é com o time do meu
celular
já usei meu celular também pra vir pra
cá utilizando um aplicativo já usei meu
celular para me comunicar com outras
pessoas
isso significa que todas essas tarefas
que a gente pode fazer usando a
tecnologia
elas nos conferem poder para fazer
alguma coisa
é eu gosto muito de uma fala que
inclusive é uma pessoa que tem um outro
ted que eu recomendo vocês assistirem
que ajudando de antares dando é ele é
uma pessoa um ativista que caminhou à
favela de antares inteira por que ele
fez isso ele fez isso porque ele tem uma
fala muito simples que diz
informação é poder a partir do momento
em que ele caminhou à favela ele pode
mostrar para aquelas pessoas que moram
naquele território ele pode ofertar
oportunidades incríveis
elas puderam procurar emprego
elas puderam abrir negócios que elas
antes não poderiam elas puderam ter
acesso a serviços públicos que ela
jamais teriam antes então tecnologia
nesse sentido ela significa que ela pode
oferecer diversas oportunidades
essa primeira que eu mencionei de que
informação significa ter acesso a mais
poder de que a gente pode ter acesso a
inúmeras tarefas né que fazemos enquanto
cidadãos de forma mais fácil de que a
gente pode atuar politicamente também
através da tecnologia
então pensando nessa chave da cidadania
é a gente vai ter alguns exemplos de
como é que a gente pode usar a
tecnologia para nos tornar cidadãos
digitais é uma das ideias por exemplo a
própria mobilização digital
se a gente pensar que as mobilizações de
junho de 2013
apesar de terem acontecido nas ruas elas
foram organizadas em sua grande parte
digitalmente através das redes sociais
a gente tem um exemplo de uma grande
transformação que aconteceu na
democracia a partir da tecnologia
a gente também ver diversos movimentos
que se organizam por exemplo através de
hash tags para mobilizar as pessoas ao
redor de alguma certa causa é o caso dos
movimentos meu primeiro assédio o meu
amigo oculto
ou mesmo a campanha admitiu que começou
nos estados unidos e se tornou global
com a mobilização digital ela é um
desses grandes exemplos né
além disso a gente pode também exercer a
nossa cidadania é pensando que podemos
fazer essa atividade de controle social
de setores enfim de órgãos do poder
público usando a tecnologia como é isso
gente pode por exemplo acessar um portal
de transparência e conhecer todos os
dados importantes que aquele órgão por
exemplo usa pra definir políticas
públicas ou mesmo a gente pode
desenvolver com inteligência artificial
um robô que faça essa própria
conferência dos gastos de parlamentares
para nos ajudar a entender se a
corrupção ou não
são inúmeros os exemplos que podem
trazer esses elementos para nós
além disso a gente pode pensar também
que a gente pode participar da política
dessa forma mais dura digamos assim
através da tecnologia e de novo são
inúmeros os exemplos para isso alguns de
vocês já assinou a uma petição online
quase todas as mãos para o alto
essas petições online muitas vezes elas
servem apenas para mobilizar as pessoas
ao redor de alguma causa mas também elas
podem ser transformadas em projetos de
lei
hoje em dia é possível sim assinar
projetos de lei de iniciativa popular
através da tecnologia usando um
aplicativo no seu celular
mas para além disso tem outras coisas
que a gente pode fazer a gente pode
manter relações duradouras com os nossos
uma vez candidatos e depois eleitos
deputados ou vereadores através do
celular também são inúmeros os
aplicativos que existem pra gente se
conectar com esses candidatos uma vez
que seus mandatos são eleitos e
monitorar aquilo que está acontecendo
aqui
o que eles estão efetivamente fazendo
quando chegam ao poder da tecnologia ela
apresenta para nós uma série de
oportunidades de como a gente pode a ser
um cidadão mais completo mas tem um
problema quando a gente fala é de quem
acessa a tecnologia ou especificamente
quem acessa a internet
a gente vai ver muitas lacunas trouxe
alguns dados aqui pra vocês terem idéia
de como funciona o acesso o não acesso à
internet no brasil são mais de 27
milhões de lares que não tem nenhum tipo
de acesso seja móvel ou fixo
as pessoas numa residência inteira que
não tem nenhum celular para acessar a
internet
são também há também uma disparidade uma
divergência muito grande em termos
regionais
as regiões norte e nordeste são as
principais afetadas por essa disparidade
existem alguns estados no norte no
nordeste que nem 50% da população têm
acesso à internet
se a gente olhar de novo para esse
número das pessoas que não têm acesso à
internet
a gente vai ver uma disparidade racial
muito significativo 60% dessas pessoas
são negras e se a gente olhar para a
classe
claramente a gente vai entender que se
as pessoas não têm acesso a comprarem um
aparelho celular ou comprarem um
computador mas não tem como ter acesso à
internet são as classes d e é são as
menos favorecidas nesse sentido tudo bem
então a gente olhou pra quem tem acesso
efetivamente a tecnologia mas há um
outro problema seria que desenha a
tecnologia fini que gerencia as grandes
empresas de tecnologia no mundo tem
alguns dados interessantes aqui mas
dentro das áreas de ciência e tecnologia
apenas 27% dos cargos são ocupados por
mulheres
mundialmente falando
além disso se a gente olhar
todas as status do vale do silício têm
essa pesquisa interessante cima do
projeto já é que conta que apenas 4%
dessas empresas são dirigidas por
mulheres negras
e se a gente olhar de novo para uma
questão regional
a disparidade entre o norte o sul global
é estarrecedor
então como é que a gente pode entender
que a tecnologia pode potencializar a
democracia se tantas pessoas estão fora
desse acesso e tantas pessoas não têm
como fazer isso então eu quis trazer
para vocês uma proposta de uma lente um
óculos que eu queria que vocês
colocassem a partir de agora junto
comigo essa que você está olhando é uma
teórica feminista norte americana negra
que se chama time oakland shopping aqui
pra mim é um grande choque ela escreve
em 88 um artigo interessantíssimo
chamado mapeando as margens
nesse artigo aqui baiana conta pra gente
sobre alguns casos que ela mesmo teve
que defender juridicamente e esses casos
eram de trabalhadores mulheres negras
que estavam sofrendo assédio nos seus
locais de trabalho e aqui para ver
quando ela teve que escrever essas
defesas
ela ficou na dúvida será que ela ia por
uma linha dizendo que aquilo que aquelas
mulheres estavam sofrendo é sexismo
ou será que ela seguia uma linha dizendo
que aquilo que aquela mulher estavam
sofrendo era racismo e ela disse é
impossível separar essas identidades
múltiplas que caracterizam aquela pessoa
aquela pessoa ela é uma mulher ela sofre
sexismo por ser mulher ela é negra e ela
sofre racismo por ser negro
então como é que eu posso dissociar
essas duas coisas então foi aí que ela
cunhou esse termo chamado
intersexualidade que essa habilidade da
gente olhar
múltiplas lentes as camadas de opressão
que afetam uma pessoa
aquelas mulheres elas não sofriam só
sexismo horas não sofriam só racismo mas
não sofri um só pelo fato de serem de
classes menos favorecidas
elas sofriam essas camadas múltiplas de
opressão
então vocês não estão vendo mas eu tô
vendo vocês viram antes eram estradas e
ruas que se cruzam e a idéia é que está
exatamente nessa intercessão essa opção
vocês viram nos dados que eu mostrei pra
vocês que as pessoas que não têm acesso
à internet ou que não têm acesso à
tecnologia o que não desenha a
tecnologia são em grande parte pessoas
que são afetadas por essas camadas
múltiplas de opressão
são pessoas que muitas vezes são negras
e de baixa renda são pessoas que estão
vivendo as margens né estão no sul
global
então eu queria trazer um pouco esse
convite pra vocês de ter esse olhar
inter seccional para quando a gente
pensar que a tecnologia pode ativar a
democracia ela pode potencializar a
democracia ela pode sim mas depende como
a gente está olhando para isso depende
de quem está por trás das grandes
empresas que desenham tecnologia que
criam tecnologia
então eu queria finalizar essa conversa
pequena contribuição dizendo pra vocês
coloquem esse óculos nem
intersexualidade pensem que não é
possível a gente destacar uma camada de
identidade de uma pessoa de outro e
quando a gente se depara com barreiras
em relação ao acesso à tecnologia não é
possível a gente transpor essas
barreiras sem um olhar inter seccional
obrigada
[Aplausos]